there's no such thing as a perfect film
more often than not there's some small
scene that prevents a movie from
achieving greatness or for some movies
even goodness for some films these
scenes can be so bad that they actually
tarnished the rest of the project as a
whole some of these movies could even
been saved if they'd left their lousy
scenes on the cutting room floor while
others were already a lost cause for
them these scenes are just the awful
icing on the crappy cake spider-man 3 to
say that Peter Parker's dance scene
ruined spider-man 3 is a bit of an
exaggeration since there's so much more
wrong with the film the misfired Sandman
CGI the underwhelming venom and James
Franco's pie-eating performance all
contributed to the flop that was
spider-man 3 but all that pales in
comparison to Peter Parker dancing at
the Jazz Club Tobey Maguire's awkward
hip thrusting and finger snapping as he
gazes through his messy banks play more
like a bad SNL sketch than anything that
ever should have made it into a
superhero movie
how many people chucked him at pop
grammar he actually said that because
seriously that's awful
The Matrix Reloaded the scene where
neophytes a crapload of Asian Smiths was
supposed to be one of the major action
set pieces for the Matrix Reloaded
but the second the fighting begins both
neo and Agent Smith get replaced with
CGI so terrible it makes the Sims look
like virtual reality the scene was meant
to follow up the groundbreaking
bullet-time effects of the first movie
instead the botched effects proved to
audiences that neither matrix sequel
would even come close to touching the
original live free or die hard John
McClane has done a lot of wildly
unrealistic things in his accidental
encounters with terrorists but none of
even come close to single-handedly
fighting and beating an actual fighter
jet live for your die hard is far from
the best movie in a series but it was
still pretty good even after being
watered down from an r-rating to a pg-13
rating that is until the filmmakers just
said f it and went to crazy town in this
scene there's the laughable ease with
which a hacker takes command of the
Marines yet - the Rube Goldberg s way
the highway perfectly falls apart to let
the Klaine escape the entire scene
should've just stayed in the imagination
of the six-year-old and probably thought
it up also how is being able to drive a
semi you know what never mind that's
actually the least ridiculous thing here
die another day with the help of a
parachute a piece of a plane and video
effects that would embarrass a high
school AV Club James Bond serves on what
appears to be a hundred foot wave of
Arctic water and die another day this
scene has been cited as the death knell
for Pierce Brosnan's pond
it took four years and the casting of
Daniel Craig the series to redeem itself
from that time a James Bond movie looked
like it was ripped from the PlayStation
2 video game cutscene but will never
forget your bond died that day Pierce
make no mistake Star Wars Episode three
Revenge of the set of the many things
that catch blame for ruining the Star
Wars prequels Jar Jar Binks
midi-chlorians almost every line of
dialogue George Lucas wrote for Padme
and Anakin I don't
there is one moment that makes almost
every fan cramps no matter how dedicated
we're talking about Anakin Skywalker's
charred transformation into Darth Vader
literally be jumping off of the entire
Star Wars saga in this moment Vader
learned he's lost his wife and unborn
children and had been transformed into
like a space Robocop what does he do he
does this
it feels silly when it should have been
tear-jerking and a cat performance by
Hayden Christensen that was so unlikable
that he went from that guy poised to be
this generation Harrison Ford to the guy
who was in that bank heist movie with
Chris Brown and Ti Jurassic Park the
lost world if you ever found yourself
being attacked by a velociraptor you
probably what your pants and run away
screaming with that in mind it's
impossible not to lose total faith in
Jurassic Park the lost world when Kelly
Malcolm the spunky daughter of dr. Ian
Malcolm stands her ground against one of
the lethal dinosaurs by putting her
gymnastic training to the test watching
a kid hold her own against one of the
franchise's nastiest villains is
undeniably cool but the way she does it
falling off and kicking the creature
through a window is entirely
unbelievable sure this is a movie about
dinosaurs being brought back to life but
Dino fighting gymnastic skills are just
a bridge too far
Lord of the Rings The Return of the King
the Lord of the Rings trilogy is
leisurely pace as part of its charm when
you watch one of these movies you know
you're setting in for a truly epic
adventure but even by those standards
the concluding chapter The Return of the
King goes on for what seems like forever
especially in the final act where it
seems to have like four or five endings
it's always hard to say goodbye to a
great cinematic saga so we can't
begrudge director Peter Jackson for his
fond photo farewell except for the scene
where the hobbits frolic on top of a bed
and gauzy light in slow motion after
spending all those hours with Frodo
Samwise the rest of the gang we want to
be laughing with them not at them
Transformers Revenge the Fallen most
people have never gone to a Transformers
movie expecting a sensible plot or
characters worth caring that much about
we line up for these things for awesome
special effects and director Michael Bay
is more than happy to deliver
unfortunately Bay isn't always content
to just blow stuff up sometimes he wants
to be funny too and that's what led to
the introduction of skids and mudflap
and revenge of the Fallen forget about
robots in disguise these two are racist
caricatures out in the open trading on
every offensive stereotype in the book
Bay litter tried to throw the voice
actors under the bus by blaming the
character's demeanor on faulty line
readings but no one bought it skids and
mudflap or even cut from the next movie
in the franchise Dark Moon Indiana Jones
and the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
by the time Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull arrived in
2008 we've been waiting for a new indie
adventure for nearly 20 years almost
nothing could have killed our buzz for
getting to spend another two hours with
our favorite archaeologist in the end
while it's no one's favorite Indiana
Jones movie most folks were willing to
forgive most of its flaws except the
infamous nuking the fridge sequence even
in a movie that asks us to suspend our
disbelief far enough to accept Indy
making contact with aliens this awful
action set piece which finds Indy
miraculously surviving a nuclear test
blast by using a lead-lined refrigerator
a shelter is laughable and ranks as one
of the few true missteps in a beloved
franchise Man of Steel the first for
Superman movies weren't all great films
by any means but they had a certain
sweetness about them that reflected the
characters optimism in the comics all
that changed when Zack Snyder took the
reins for 2013's Man of Steel although
darker overtones were probably to be
expected in the post dark night world it
was still difficult for many longtime
fans to accept the rampant casual
destruction Superman helped unleashed
during his battle with Zod in the final
act even harder to accept was this
decision to end the fight by snapping
Zod's neck Snyder has defended his
decision repeatedly but that plot point
remains the focus of intense debate for
some fans it undermines the entire
concept of the character and when they
saw it go down in the theater they had
one unavoidable reaction thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know what ridiculous movie scenes
you think should have made the list